le deuxième cette semaine thomas saint
germain m'avait parlé de lui
car lille avait évoqué le statut de
l'élu 10 heures chaque mardi conférence
est les sept journalistes de la
rédaction près par le journal à venir
toutes les nouvelles et dans les
kiosques chaque mercredi l'hebdomadaire
pendant une semaine on détermine les
sujets et bien sûr on essaye de coller
au plus près de la réalité et de
l'actualité donc il ya des sujets qui
vont nécessairement peut-être prendre
plus d'ampleur
et bien sûr on s'adapte donc
quotidiennement à l'élaboration de sora
et ce jour là deux de ses journalistes
couvrent saint quentin en yvelines elle
l'un d'entre eux alexandre marque et
fait parler sa plume depuis 15 ans
occupe de tout ce qui se passe sur saint
quentin en yvelines
je reste et c'est d'être au courant de
tout ce qui se passe d' intéressant
d'innovant voilà pour les infos locales
le sport fait divers dossiers
bettencourt en un peu tout ce qui se
fait sur le secteur bonjour d'aprés
maintient là le reportage est un sujet
d'annonce alexandre rencontre deux
membres d'associations organisatrices
d'un festival à la maison de l'étudiant
de l'université
lorsqu'on a voulu envisager c'est un
projet culturel ouvert aux étudiants
mais aussi aux huit ans à 30 ans à des
structures que souvent les gens nous
achète aussi pour avoir les annonces de
ce qui va se passer le week-end donc
aussi j'ai même envie de dire on est
même peut-être plus là plus intérêts
afin de l' annonce que du contenu
alexandre s'occupe de six à huit
reportages par semaine l'écriture du
sujet peut se faire le jour même ou le
lendemain j'ai pris j'ai pris des notes
sur mon cahier
et puis donc je vais dire lire et je
vais essayer de construire mon article
faire une sorte de une rédaction comme
une dissertation un peu en essayant le
organiser un peu mes idées et après je
vais écrire directement donc dans un
bloc un bloc texte et puis après je mets
tout mon forme je rajoute un titre
rajoute une légende pour pour la photo
1h d'écriture par article le lundi le
journal doit être bouclé